what i have depicted right over here is
a fairly typical sn2 reaction we see
this hydroxide it substitutes this
bromine it becomes a hydroxyl group the
bromine takes so it gives this pair to
form this bond
then this bond and the both of those
electrons go to the bromine and now that
becomes the bromide anion so we've seen
this multiple times but what i want to
really study in this video is what
happens to the handedness of these
molecules or to the this molecule right
over here i guess you could say to the
substrate although obviously one one
group gets substituted with another so
let's name this thing right over here
so if we start counting at this carbon
one
two
three
four four carbon backbone it is all
single bonds this is a butane this is a
butane
butane and then it has a bromine at the
number two carbon so this is two
bromobutane so let me write this two
bromo
two bromobutane
and then after this reaction it becomes
so once again we still have four carbons
but now instead of a bromogroup we have
a hydroxyl group which makes this an
alcohol so instead of just calling it
instead of just calling it butane
instead of just calling it butane
butane we would now call it butanol
butanol because of this hydroxyl group
right over here butanol right over here
and the hydroxyl group is attached to
the one
two
so this is one two carbon so this is two
two butanol but what i really want to
think about is the chirality or the
handedness and we see here this carbon
in both cases it is a chiral carbon the
four things that it is bonded to are all
different a bromine a ch3 a hydrogen and
then you could kind of view this as a of
an ethyl group it has it's bonded to two
carbons right over here so these are all
different so we can think about its
handedness same here bonded to four
different things
so whenever you're thinking about
chirality the convention is take the
take the thing that it's bonded to that
has the lowest atomic number and put
that in the back well hydrogen has the
lowest atomic number out of all of these
four things so you can imagine that
being put into the back and in fact it's
already drawn that way so it's kind of
going into
into the screen so we'll focus on these
three things right out here and the
convention is start with the thing that
has the highest atomic number and the
thing that has the highest atomic number
is the bromine
is the bromine out of the four things
that this this chiral carbon is bonded
to and then go in the order and then
rotate in the order of where the next
highest atomic number is well you say
well you have a carbon there carbon
there they have the same atomic number
but then you go to what it's bonded to
for the tiebreaker and this is bonded to
three hydrogens this is bonded to two
hydrogens and then another carbon so
this extra carbon breaks that atomic
number tiebreaker so we go in this
direction we go in this direction
right over here
and the way i think about is what's
happening at the top well we're moving
to the right we're moving in the
clockwise directions so we would call
this r
r two bromobutane and we have other
videos we're going to much more detail
about naming chiral co
naming chiral molecules but i like to
think about what's happening at top r my
little mnemonic and my head is off or
right r2 bromobutane is right over here
now let's think about what's going on
here
once again put the hydrogen in the back
it has the lowest has the lowest atomic
number and so we'll focus on the carbons
and the oxygen out of carbons and oxygen
oxygen has the highest atomic number
oxygen has the highest atomic number and
then we'll move in the direction of the
next highest well once again the ch2 ch3
the c's have the same atomic number but
then the tie breaker is when you think
about what it's moditude this is bonded
to another carbon while this is all
hydrogens so we move in this direction
we move
we move in this direction or
counterclockwise direction and our
chirality naming conventions is we would
say s
s for sinister s2
butanol
now the whole reason why i
went through this exercise is to show
you that in this sn2 in this sn2
reaction the handedness the chirality
has changed
for the molecule you can imagine that
this if you imagine that over here this
two bromobutane if this was an umbrella
where the bromine is kind of the handle
and this is kind of an upward turn
umbrella all of a sudden the nucleophile
comes in the leaving group the leaving
group pops off and then the umbrella
pops off or the umbrella goes in the
other direction it has kind of changed
because the the nucleophile is coming
from the left side the leaving group is
leaving from the right it has changed
its handedness
and the reason why this is interesting
as well because you know an sn2 reaction
this now changed i went from r to s
in an sn1 reaction as we'll see because
an sn1 reaction the nucleophile leaves
on its own and then the nucleus sorry
the leaving group leaves on its own and
then the nucleophile comes in and it can
come in from any side so with an sn1
reaction you get a mix you might switch
handedness or you might not switch
handedness so the whole point of this
video is to get you a little bit more
thinking a little bit more about this
about the stereochemistry and the
handedness of sn2 reactions